das wäre eine katastrophe für die
astronomie für die satellitenbasierte
kommunikationstechnologie sollen
abertausende von satelliten in den orbit
geschickt werden schon jetzt starten
fast monatlich raketen die dutzende von
satelliten ins all bringen die
wissenschaft hat schon länger angst dass
in zukunft nur noch einen satelliten
himmel anstatt eines sternenhimmels
beobachtet werden kann
und jetzt gibt es erstmals eine studie
zu den gefahren der satelliten netze
ihre ergebnisse für die forschung sind
der schrecken fixum science fiction
jackie spannende science wedels
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks um
gibt es jetzt mit dem wissenschafts news
auch täglich als audio podcast die links
zum podcast bei spotify und apple sind
unten in der video beschreibung in der
raumfahrt gibt es gerade so etwas wie
eine revolution noch vor zehn jahren gab
es etwa 1000 funktionierende satelliten
diese zahl hat sich mittlerweile
verdoppelt und schon in weiteren zehn
jahren könnten es unglaubliche 20.000
satelliten sein die die erde umkreisen
die flugkörper die einst in handarbeit
hergestellt wurden werden jetzt zur
echten massenware die jeden winkel
unseres planeten mit internet versorgen
sollen schon im letzten jahr kamen
besorgte stimmen aus der astronomie auf
weil die tausenden flugkörper in zukunft
den blick durch teleskope extrem stören
können da sie sonnenlicht reflektieren
das von ihnen gegründete amerikanische
unternehmen spacex arbeitet an einem
satelliten netzwerk namens starling mich
erreichen ständig mails oder nachrichten
auf instagram die frau ich habe wieder
so eine kette von satelliten gesehen
oder von lichtpunkten was ist das
satelliten die zwischen 340 und 1300
kilometern um die erde kreisen sollen
die ganze erde mit high speed internet
versorgen das sogar noch schnellere
geschwindigkeiten als glasfaserkabel
erreichen soll
dafür sollen insgesamt sogar 40.000
flugkörpern saal geschickt werden das
ist wirklich eine krasse zahl und man
kann sich kaum vorstellen was dann über
unseren köpfen los sein wird bisher
wurden schon weit über 300 davon
losgeschickt und tausende sollen folgen
von den sorgen der astronomie zeigt sich
allen masc aber unbeeindruckt und meint
die gefahr für die bodengebundene
astronomie läge bei null starling
experimentiert mit einer dunklen
beschichtung die die reflektivität der
satellit
minimieren sollen fachleute aus der
astronomie sehen das natürlich ganz
anders seit dem vergangenen frühjahr die
ersten satelliten gestartet sind
versucht die fachwelt einzuschätzen wie
dramatisch die auswirkungen der
tausenden satelliten im erdorbit sein
werden jetzt gibt es eine erste studie
zu den mega konstellationen die
europäische südsternwarte eso zeigt
darin die verheerenden konsequenzen für
die beobachtung mit eso teleskopen dabei
geht es daran erstmal nur um instrumente
die im optischen und infraroten bereich
des elektromagnetischen spektrums
arbeiten es stehen also noch zwei
weitere studien aus eine zum effekt der
millimeter und submillimeterbereich und
eine zu den radio wellenlängen die
arbeit berücksichtigt neben maske
styling konstellation alle momentan
geplanten konstellation also insgesamt
das sind 18 stück der absolute wahnsinn
die von unternehmen wie amazon web
geplant werden insgesamt rechnet die
studie mit 26.000 satelliten die sich
voraussichtlich gleichmäßig um die erde
verteilen werden wahrscheinlich werden
direkt nach sonnenuntergang beim
mittleren breitengraden rund 1600
satelliten sonnenlicht zur erde
reflektieren im laufe der nacht sinkt
diese zahl dann bis auf 1100 ab das gute
ist dass viele der satelliten sich nach
dem modell nahe am horizont bewegen und
nicht hell genug wären um sie mit dem
bloßen auge zu erkennen eine der großen
sorgen dass es mehr satelliten als
sichtbare stern am himmel geben wird
scheint also erst mal übertrieben aber
astronomische beobachtungen werden
schließlich nicht mit bloßem auge
gemacht und je nach beobachtungsort kann
die auswirkungen der konstellation stark
variieren zumindest sehr kurze
belichtung von etwa einer sekunde werden
tatsächlich nicht beeinträchtigt die
schlechte nachricht ist aber dass wir
länger die beobachtungen dauernd umso
mehr aufnahmen durch die satelliten
ruiniert werden für die meisten
teleskope bedeutet dass einschränkungen
im bereich weniger prozent das klingt
noch relativ harmlos das wirkliche
problem ist aber dass große teleskope
die einen weiten bereich des himmels
abdecken dramatisch gestört werden dazu
gehört zum beispiel das wäre als rubin
observatorium das gerade in chile gebaut
wird dieses mega teleskop soll ab 2022
jede nacht eine fläche beobachten die
40.000 mal so groß ist wie der vollmond
und so wertvolle daten sammeln nachdem
schätzung wäre der schaden wirklich
krass ganze 30 bis 50 prozent aller
aufnahmen
durch den satelliten spuren beschädigt
werden um das auszugleichen müsste das
teleskop statt der geplanten zehn jahre
sogar 14 jahre laufen um die erhofften
daten zu bekommen bei null liegt das
risiko also wirklich nicht ein weiteres
ernstzunehmendes problem ist der verlust
für beobachtung von nur kurzzeitig
auftretende phänomen dazu gehört auch
die entdeckung von asteroiden und
kometen auch hier können wichtige
informationen für die wissenschaft
verloren gehen die situation ist aus
astronomischer sicht also wirklich
bedrohlich und jetzt bleibt abzuwarten
welche folgen auf beobachtung mit
anderen wellenlängen zu kommen die
plastischen verluste wird wohl die
radioastronomie erfahren die frage ist
aber ob diese entwicklung überhaupt noch
aufgehalten werden kann
es gibt jedenfalls ein aufruf des
petitionsausschusses des deutschen
bundestages darin werden alle
raumfahrtunternehmen zur verringerung
der satelliten anzahl aufgerufen und es
wird ein weltweiter ausschuss gefordert
der in zukunft solche satellitenprojekte
bewilligen soll
denn abgesehen von den einbußen für die
forschung gibt es noch eine zweite
heftige gefahr die die
satellitenbasierte
kommunikationstechnologie noch
verschlimmern wird weltraumschrott die
größte gefahr im weltall kann sie
beseitigt werden anklicken anschauen und
klickst um science-fiction das ist
übrigens dieser kanal hier abonnieren
es wäre klasse also bis dann bleibt dran